hallo mein name ist zusätzlich will
kommen heute zu einem neuen video hier
seht schon meine schnauze hier ein
bisschen rot war der name dass ich dir
einfach daran weil ich mir so ein tolles
ding im elektro fachleuten gekauft habe
wo wir jetzt automatisch schon los oder
warten wir gar nicht drumherum reden ich
habe nur gehört dass die oculus rift
1000 euro kostet ab mir gedacht ich habe
kein geld deswegen link für 12 euro
gekauft und hat sogar schon augen denn
die zum teil das setzt man sich in die
schnauze und mein gott es tun halten nur
noch weg okay ich bin jetzt hier um mein
gott okay er fährt einfach alter schwede
ich habe dass ich hab das ding
tatsächlich gerade 4
mir ist übel schlecht also ich muss das
quasi runterziehen meine nase
so fahre ich auch machthabern er springt
von einem gleis zum anderen menschheit
ist er wie die deutsche bahn hierdurch
jahr wahrscheinlich weil dadurch wasser
nächtlicher das also dass es gibt quasi
darum ich kann mich jetzt so bewegen und
ihr seht schon wenn dir das mal
vergleich das gameplay mit seiner
schnauze was ich hier gerade anrichte
kann nicht wahr sie das sehen was sich
was ach komm doch einfach noch eine
strecke da wo ich hingucke machte er
sein dass bin gegen mikroben schmeller
der kraxe sich hier gerade die scheiße
hoch und mit es ist kommt mit
tatsächlich so vor als wenn er das nicht
schaffen würde
daran ist auch ultra gut gesichert wir
hängen so komisch ich kann auch ich werd
nicht mehr so ist das okay okay
ich bin echt kurzform kotzen das ist auf
jeden fall sein roller kurz das spiel
was ich mir da runter geladen habe fürs
iphone jetzt also ich hab da quasi
wirklich das ist kein placement oder
glaub ich hab sie einfach hier das ist
ein pub ding und habe ich einfach mal
ein iphone or eingeklemmt sogar mit
einem gummiband ich sehe doch alle wie
sie htc bei videos machen und hat den
vorteil aus 1000 euro nicht denken
ich habe zwölf euro für den stahl ein
paar sekunden später ich habe jetzt
einfach noch ein zweites game
runtergeladen und zwar rsv er da kann
ich die bringe ich mir das schon
aussetzen weil ich noch dass der race
daten muss ich klicke einfach mal auf
start race klickt man auf free flight
macht mir das jetzt mal ganz schnell
mein gott es gibt schon gelingt die
schlange auf mallorca hat ich habe mir
viel pro-version gekaufte drei euro was
passiert wenn ich ihn hier in ein
hochhaus ging wie er war jetzt einfach
tod habe ich eigentlich ein
wasserflugzeug
aber wahrscheinlich explodieren im
wasser also es tut halt echt so
unfassbar wenig ich kann es nicht in
worte fassen wie sehr das auf meiner
nase gerade schmerzt das free flight
gerade also ich kann dir jetzt ehemann
ich bin mir meiner oben geflogen ich
jetzt nach unten schaut mein gott okay
ich war ich relativ erfreulich versuche
etwas riskantes und zwar fliege ich
zwischen diesen hochhäusern her was ich
hätte das geschafft ist nicht wieder
einmal ist wie für mich gemacht einfach
nach oben fliegen immer schön in den
himmel schauen distrito unter 150 800
insolvenzen nicht einsammeln muss dass
sie sich auf den jachthafen ich versuche
mal relativ nah dahin zu bringen damit
wir uns die boote da anschauen können an
dem ihr was ist das denn
das ist dass sie fliegen mal hier dran
vorbei fliegen ja meine kleine
was mich schlecht da oben sieht so aus
als ob ich das durchfliegen kann luca uk
merkel wir sind unserer guten höhe
fliegen jetzt hier lang und kann ich
dadurch bekommt egal wenn ich das jetzt
nicht machen kann er dann ich bin besser
pilot eu habe ich sammle man hier noch
die münze heim
new york dpa afx breit von 50 münzen ist
eine münze die könnte ich mir aber okay
okay okay wir verlieren ja ich bin nicht
gemacht für dieses spiel
alter schwede ihr amt nicht oh mein gott
guckt euch meine sachen die rot ist
bittet man das flugzeug pilot luca beck
gerne ledig da unten gönne ich mir doch
direkt an münzen würden gelöscht
verdammt freue mich nehmen die scheiße
hier mal auf ich bin mich hat das total
zerlegt also ich habe gerade echt
bauchschmerzen ich habe meine nase tut
so unfassbar weh gerade ich hoffe euch
hat das video gefallen ich habe jetzt
nur zwei games gezockt er ich habe mir
noch horror spiel heruntergeladen wollte
vielleicht den zweiten teil wo ich dann
einfach mal so zwei drei hocker spieler
aus teste alter schwede meine ganzen
augen meiner nase meine stirn tun wie
seht ihr das alter guckt euch allein mal
diese spielen ja also ich glaub die
oculus rift ist tatsächlich ein bisschen
bequemer wenn euch das video gefallen
hat würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen schreibt mir die kommentare ob
ihren horror teil davon haben wollt und
sonst der typ fliegt hier immer
doch irgendwo hinkommen wir beobachten
ganz kurz alleine hinfliegt ich habe
keine kontrolle war das flugzeug und
fliegt direkt in ein hochhaus rollen
damit beende ich das heutige video